well all this week we're looking at
healthy habits for the new year you know
you always hear me encourage you to
drink more water in our dry climate but
it's not just a matter of quenching your
thirst no water is vital for our overall
well-being in so many ways and knowing
the power that it holds for a healthy
body and mind will likely change your
drinking habits starting maybe today
do you think about drinking water only
when you're thirsty it may surprise you
to know that many parts of our body that
depend on h2o to function may already be
on the way to dehydration by then up to
60 percent of our body weight is water
all of our vital organs especially our
brains hold even more and babies believe
it or not are up to eighty percent water
water feeds our body's cells to rebuild
and regulates our internal temperature
through sweat and breathing it
lubricates our joints and acts as a
shock absorber for our brain and spinal
cord we can't produce saliva without
water it metabolizes and carries the
food we eat through our bloodstream and
then works to flush waste and toxins out
even mild dehydration can impair your
mood your memory and your brain
performance headaches confusion muscle
cramps and constipation can all be
thanks to too little h2o
so how much water do we need to perform
at our peak every day an average adult
should drink between two and three
quarts of water that's 64 to 96 ounces
more if you're an aggressive exerciser
it's not unusual to lose one to three
percent of body weight through normal
daily activities exercise or high heat
which we certainly get a lot of here in
the desert